good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson
tonight on inauguration day 2017 it's
likely that not one in a hundred
thousand Americans was thinking about
rush it was the last thing most people
were thinking about the cold war had
ended peacefully more than 25 years
before Moscow was no longer America's
main strategic rival as it had been for
50 years Russia had been downgraded
instead to the status of a regional
power consumed with disputes with
obscure places like Ukraine in the
American media there were more stories
about Russian alcoholism than there were
about Russian ICBMs but in the White
House in Washington that morning Russia
was very much the main topic it was
January 20th the last day of the Obama
administration outgoing National
Security Advisor Susan Rice sat down at
her desk to write her final memo rice
described the presidential transition
which had been underway for months then
she wrote this during a meeting two
weeks before quote President Obama said
he wants to be sure that as we engage
with the incoming team we are mindful to
ascertain if there is any reason we
cannot share information fully as it
relates to Russia now rice did not
explain why Obama's staff felt it might
not be possible to give intelligence on
Russia to Donald Trump's staff or for
that matter why the Obama people thought
they had the right to withhold national
security information from an incoming
American president who had just won a
national election but rice didn't need
to elaborate there was only one possible
explanation for this
Donald Trump could very well be a
Russian agent Barack Obama himself said
he believed that was possible in Rice's
words quote the president asked Jim
Comey to inform him if anything changes
in the next few weeks that should affect
how we share classified information with
the incoming team Comey said he would
now what exactly does that mean here's
what it means the President of the
United States turned to the head of the
FBI the most powerful law enforcement
official in America and said continue to
secretly investigate my chief political
rival so that I can act against him
commis responds yes sir that's what
Obama was saying openly in any normal
period in
in history this exchange would define
Barack Obama forever Obama would be
known as the disgraced former president
who used federal law enforcement to hurt
his political enemies that's what he did
unfortunately this is not a normal
period already today Obama's order that
Comey investigate Donald Trump has been
relegated to a little-known footnote Joe
Biden happened to be sitting in the room
when this happened has Biden ever been
asked about that it's possible he never
has been most media outlets have ignored
the origins of the Russia conspiracy
hoax completely and as a result of that
Barack Obama's plan to derail his
successor unfolded with very little
opposition along the way including from
Republicans the entire country therefore
spent the first three years of the Trump
administration hyperventilating about
Russian collusion that did not exist
Susan Rice assiduously did her part to
help it along
here's rice in July of 2017 a year and a
half later suggesting a network
television the President of the United
States was indeed working for Vladimir
Putin he's taken a series of steps that
had Vladimir Putin dictated them he
couldn't have mirrored more effectively
what his motivations are I think is a
legitimate question one that I trust
that the special counsel is
investigating but the policies that this
president has pursued globally have
served Vladimir Putin's interests in
dividing the West's undermining
democracy does that mean you think it's
an open question whether or not he's
compromised by Russia George I don't
know what his motivations are I think
that's a legitimate question
in fact it was never a quote legitimate
question it was a reckless slur the most
reckless possible slur the kind that
damages a whole country along with a
politician it's aimed at rice knew
perfectly well there was no evidence at
all that Donald Trump had ever worked
for Russia we know that she believed
that because she admitted as much under
oath in a closed-door hearing in
Congress as rice explained to the House
Intelligence Committee the reason she
was willing to accuse Trump officials of
treason against their own country was
that some of them seemed unduly worried
about the rise of China here's what
susan rice for example said about
General Michael Flynn
quote general Flynn's focus was on China
as our principal overarching adversary
he had many questions and concerns about
China and when I sought to elicit his
perspective on Russia he downplayed his
assessment of Russia as a threat to the
United States he called it overblown he
said they were declining power there
demographically challenged they're not
really much of a threat and then re
emphasize the importance of China I had
seen enough at that point and heard
enough to be a little bit sensitive to
the question of the nature of general
flynn's engagements with the Russians
did you follow that
because Michael Flynn correctly
described Russia as a declining power
and then went on to criticize Susan
Rice's close friends in the Chinese
government Susan Rice concluded the
general Flynn must be a Putin spy this
is idiotic and it's crazy it's hard to
believe that Susan Rice was once
national security adviser of the United
States but she was Evelyn Farkas was
once Barack Obama's Deputy Assistant
Secretary of Defense Farkas repeatedly
went on television to say there was
ample evidence the Trump administration
was colluding with Russia and yet like
Susan Rice Farkas said something
completely different under oath before
Congress quote I didn't know anything
she admitted now we quoted Evelyn Farkas
saying that on this show on Friday
Farkas responded to us by claiming that
we were quote missing some key facts now
originally she agreed to come on tonight
and explain what those key facts might
be she is running for Congress now in
New York unfortunately then Evelyn
Farkas backed out but we fervently hope
she comes back to tell us what those
might be we'd like to speak to Barack
Obama too that's unlikely he'll have to
settle for what he has told his friends
on Friday Obama had a purportedly
private call with supporters that of
course was immediately leaked to the
media in it the man whose sixth law
enforcement on his political rivals
accused the current administration of
undermining the rule of law that's the
kind of stuff where you you begin to get
worried then basic
not just institutional norms but our
basic understanding of rule of law is is
is is it risk institutional norms these
people are nothing if not predictable
what she just heard as always was
textbook projection you see it again and
again and again what they accuse you of
doing
they are eagerly doing themselves the
rule of law Yelp's Obama
it's almost amusing the press doesn't
find it funny in the slightest they see
no irony at all they repeated verbatim
with solemn faces over the weekend Chuck
Todd of NBC accused the Attorney General
Bill Barr of gutting the rule of law of
ignoring it completely and to prove that
Chuck Todd used what seemed to be quite
a damning quote watch this I want you to
listen to this bill Barr answer to a
question about what will history say
about this way do you hear this answer
take a listen when history looks back on
this decision how do you think it will
be written well history is written by
the winners so it's largely depends on
who's writing the history I was struck
PEGI by the cynicism of the answer it's
a correct answer but he's the Attorney
General he didn't make the case that he
was upholding the rule of law struck by
the cynicism Chuck Todd who is married
to a political stunt consultant was just
struck by the cynicism he could barely
believe it he was stunned bill Barr
didn't even mention upholding the rule
of a kind of a major admission omission
for an attorney general but wait it
turns out that bill Barr did mention the
rule of law it was at the center of his
answer now that was a CBS tape NBC got
ahold of it and edit out the words to
distort bill Bars meaning we have the
real tape here it is when history looks
back
on this decision how do you think it
will be written well history is written
by the winners so it's largely depends
on who's writing the history but I think
a fair history would say it was it was a
good decision because it upheld the rule
of law yeah to be clear catherine
herridge did not edit that tape she did
a straightforward interview NBC News
edited the tape now if you're shocked
that a news network could be that openly
and aggressively dishonest so buffoonish
ly dishonest then you haven't been
paying very close attention for the past
four years they've been doing it since
day one with the Russia hoax and they
don't plan to stop now